Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
En 1997 en un partido
entre Francia y Brasil,
un joven jugador brasileño
llamado Roberto Carlos
se preparó para
un tiro libre de 35 metros.
Sin línea directa a la portería,
Carlos decidió intentar
lo que parecía imposible.
Su patada envió el balón
esquivando a los jugadores,
pero antes de irse fuera del campo,
se enganchó a la izquierda
y entró en la portería.
Según la primera ley
del movimiento de Newton,
un objeto se moverá
en la misma dirección y velocidad
hasta que una fuerza se aplique en él.
Cuando Carlos pateó la pelota,
le dio dirección y velocidad,
pero ¿qué fuerza hizo virar la bola
y marcar uno de los goles más magníficos
en la historia de este deporte?
El truco estaba en el giro.
Carlos puso su patada en la esquina
inferior derecha de la pelota,
enviándola alta y a la derecha, pero
girándola alrededor de su eje.
La pelota comenzó su vuelo
en una aparente ruta directa,
con el aire fluyendo
en ambos lados frenándola.
Por un lado, el aire se mueve en
la dirección opuesta a la rotación
de la bola, produciendo
un aumento de presión;
por el otro lado, el aire se mueve
en la misma dirección del giro,
creando un área de baja presión.
Esa diferencia
hace que la curva del balón se dirija
hacia la zona de presión más baja.
Este fenómeno se conoce
como efecto Magnus.
Este tipo de patada que se denomina,
a menudo, saque de banana,
se intenta regularmente,
y es uno de los elementos que hacen
a este juego maravilloso, hermoso.
Pero curvar el balón
con la precisión necesaria
en la curva alrededor de la barrera
y en la caída a la meta, es difícil.
Demasiado alto y
se eleva sobre el objetivo.
Demasiado bajo y toca el suelo
antes de curvarse.
Demasiado amplia y
nunca llega a la meta.
No es lo suficientemente amplia y
los defensas lo interceptan.
Demasiado lento y engancha
demasiado pronto, o nada en absoluto.
Demasiado rápido y engancha
demasiado tarde.
La misma física hace posible
marcar un gol aparentemente imposible,
un córner olímpico.
El efecto Magnus fue documentado
por primera vez por Sir Isaac Newton
tras notarlo en 1670
durante un partido de tenis.
También se aplica a las pelotas de golf,
frisbees y pelotas de béisbol.
En todos los casos, ocurre lo mismo.
El giro de la bola crea una diferencia
de presión en el flujo de aire circundante
que se curva en la dirección del giro.
Y he aquí una pregunta.
¿Podrías teóricamente patear
una pelota lo suficiente
como para que hiciera un boomerang
y volviera de nuevo a ti?
Por desgracia, no.
Incluso si la pelota no
se desintegra en el impacto,
ni golpea ningún obstáculo,
al desacelerarla el aire,
el ángulo de deflexión aumentaría,
haciendo círculos en espiral
cada vez más pequeños
hasta detenerse finalmente.
Y solo para obtener esa espiral,
se tendría que hacer girar
la bola 15 veces más rápido
que el saque inmortal de Carlos.
Así que buena suerte con eso.